- Okay, welcome everybody.
Thank you for making the time.
I know it's quite a taxing few days,
so appreciate you guys coming out.
And, yeah, today's focus is really about
talking about how we simplify solutions.
So, focus is on complexity
of customer experience.
And how we are working with AWS
to really simplify and
make that effortless.
So as an introduction,
I'm Sashen Naidu, the Executive Head
of our Global Customer
Experience Practice.
And I'm joined by Priyen Pillay.
So Priyen will be joining me in a bit
and getting into a little bit more detail
on some of the solutions we're doing,
as well as the innovation
we are working with with AWS
and with a few of our clients.
So I'd like to share just
in terms of the agenda,
a lot about our partnership,
it's been a fantastic journey.
So, you know, coming
back to my role at NTT,
I've been here for 17 years,
and really been in the contact center
and customer experience space.
So once upon a time,
with our business process
services business,
looking after contact center operations.
My focus over the last 10 years
has been with a number of
our different CX partners.
And really, the focus over
the last six years has been,
how can we build solutions and services,
not just transactional capabilities,
but really partnering and
building value for clients?
I'm gonna talk about
digital transformation
and I know it's a, you know, hot topic,
you guys are discussing it every day.
But I wanna share our thinking
in terms of what we're seeing,
some of the challenges we're seeing.
And how we are actually addressing those.
You know, once again, you know,
I'd love to just give
you guys some insights
because it's challenges
that we've experienced,
and I'm sure you guys
are experiencing similar,
and how we've actually
worked through those.
I'll go into a bit of detail
on our Connect portfolio
and the depth of services,
really important is we've taken
a full lifecycle approach.
So from concept through to
execution and management,
our focus is really covering
that entire lifecycle.
Another interesting topic is AI agents
versus human agents.
Lots of AI, I think not a day goes by,
or probably not an hour
goes by without somebody
mentioning AI or agentic AI.
But the reality is that
we're starting to see
a lot of adoption, real use cases.
So I'll take you through
some of the thinking around
where humans are still really important.
On the innovation side,
we've really looked
at how we can actually address challenges,
how we can address gaps in
terms of the current solution.
So I wanna go through some
of what we've done as NTT.
But, more importantly, all
of these have been born
out of client challenges
that we need to address.
Priyen will go through a lot more about
how Amazon Connect has
really changed the landscape
from CCAS to composable CX solutions,
and why Amazon Connect is so different
when we talk about customer experience.
He'll also talk to a lot
more of the innovation,
IP and accelerators that we've built,
in the specific use cases
where we've deployed it,
across different verticals.
And just to give you guys some insights
in terms of what we've
done and how we've done it.
Priyen will also go through
some of the use cases.
You know, for me it's important
to talk about theoretical solutions.
Most important is, where
have we put it into practice?
What value is it adding? What
problems is it addressing?
And Priyen will also go through
the agentic AI framework
because what's really important is,
AI has to be a native part of
any solution going forward.
It's not an afterthought,
it's not an add-on,
it's got to be part and parcel
of those initial conversations
and how you build out solutions.
So if I just share
a little bit more about our partnership,
when I talk about a consultative approach,
you know, as NTT and I
mentioned my background
in contact centers and operations,
we've had over 40 years of experience
running and operating contact centers.
And this is really important
because our approach
has not been one from a technology,
or systems integrator perspective.
But how do you consume that technology?
How does it add value to your operations?
And operations from an agent
through to supervisor,
through to management.
What we've really done and, you know,
deliberately we focus more on advisory
than typical consulting,
because it's not about
art of the possible.
How do you build out focused
advisory capabilities based
on client requirements?
Typically what we do is we
do one or two week workshops.
And the focus is, how can we add value
through the adoption of technology?
If we look at AI, once again,
I know it needs no introduction,
but AI, we've seen
especially in contact
center, is multiple layers.
So, you know, everybody's
talking about it now,
but we've seen it.
You guys have seen it in
the contact center space,
robotics and process automation, IVR.
So when I look at AI, gen AI,
agentic AI, it's really the evolution
of where we started off with RPA and IVR.
In fact, you know, agentic
AI to me is replacing
what we've done for a
number of years with IVR.
Sure, it's completely autonomous
depending on the different use cases,
a lot more insights and analytics.
But it's really important,
is how we actually build
out those solutions.
And when we look at customer experience,
another really important,
you know, everybody says,
"Oh, contact center," I said "No,"
'cause customer experience
is so much more.
It is about the entire ecosystem,
of which CCAS is usually one
of the foundational components.
And that is where, once
again, Connect as a platform.
You know, a few years ago,
there was a lot of hesitation
in terms of adopting Connect.
And the reason for that
is a lot of people said,
"well, you've got to have a
lot of DevOps capabilities
and it's a black box."
But what we've seen is
that a lot of the maturity
that has been put into
delivering use cases.
And if you look at the
entire AWS ecosystem,
all of the reporting and
analytics, all of the intelligence,
all of that wrapped around Connect
is where Amazon differentiates.
Another interesting topic and, you know,
I wanna talk a lot more,
I'll get into some detail,
around AI-driven sourcing.
How do you use AI
to drive your sourcing
and people strategy?
One of the reasons that AI
is actually really prevalent
and adding value in the
customer experience space
is because, you know, we've seen the trend
of onshoring to offshoring
to lower cost geographies.
But now AI has completely
shifted that mindset.
You can do onshoring,
especially in verticals where,
you know, there's highly sensitive data,
and there's reasons in terms
of being able to manage,
you know, data sensitivity.
But AI can drive that out
with significant cost savings.
And I'm gonna get into a lot more detail.
A focus around industry
specific CX solutions,
and this is where service
as software comes in,
where we're looking at
deep domain expertise.
We're looking at the platforms and tools
that deliver a particular outcome.
You know, people talk about outcomes
and that's another fantastic buzzword,
but how do you deliver that?
So our focus has been
creating those solutions
that are not generic,
but they are specific.
So if we look at a particular vertical,
like financial services or insurance,
some of the things that we are doing
and working with clients is,
how do you focus on delivering
those services, those outcomes?
So it could be, in the insurance world,
focus on processing
claims or policy admin.
It is not about seats and licenses
and processes, it's about outcomes.
And then on the innovation side,
I really wanna share, and I
mentioned, what we've done,
how we've done it, and
how it pieces together
in these broader solutions.
If I look at digital
transformation and, you know,
these are interesting themes.
So elevating CX.
Everybody talks about
hyper-personalization,
how do you do that?
Well, with the right solutions,
access to the data in real-time
with AI natively embedded.
You can make data either available
to an agentic AI solution,
or through to a person
where you're augmenting
that person's capabilities.
So, you know, really AWS's ability
to deliver full stack
composable solutions.
And that word to me is really key,
the composability of the solution.
You could start with a
foundational solution,
and build it up
based on requirements that
change, new business systems.
And as we see businesses starting
to evolve their strategy,
you need platforms that are
gonna support that evolution.
If I look at migration to modern CX,
we've seen the move from on-prem
to hosted to cloud native.
You know, even on cloud native,
everybody has a different
view of what cloud native is.
But what's really important
is, it's not just about cloud,
it's about AI native
cloud, it's about AI first.
How do you build these solutions
with the right insights
and the right capabilities?
Another really important
theme and capability
is having a tightly integrated solution.
And I'm gonna talk about
total experience in a minute.
So it is about delivering
customer experience,
employee experience, digital experience,
all coming together,
delivering it with voice,
delivering it with managed services.
And putting it together
as one cohesive solution.
And I think last, but certainly not least,
we tend to forget about
human-centric capabilities,
human in the loop.
As much as we've seen AI,
we've seen adoption of AI,
you guys have seen the announcements,
I think they're fantastic in
terms of what AWS is doing,
the level of autonomy.
But make no mistake,
we are gonna continue
to have people engaged,
but elevating the role
that people are gonna play
in different solutions,
especially in customer experience.
I'm gonna talk to a lot more
of where we're seeing the roles change
to more of supervisory,
compliance, governance.
And, really, how people are supporting
a lot of the quality outputs
that want AI and agentic
AI solutions to deliver.
So I briefly mentioned
it, total experience.
If you guys are not familiar, you know,
when we talk about experience,
and CX is something
that's close to my heart,
as you can probably tell,
but it's not just about
customer experience.
It's about employee experience,
it's about the agents
that enable that engagement
with your end clients.
It's about the AI and the
experience that they deliver.
So when we talk about total experience,
it is about stitching
together what we would call
customer experience, employee experience,
user experience, digital experience.
And piecing all of that together.
So having a platform that
is tightly integrated.
More importantly, natively able
to deliver all of these solutions
means that you can
actually deliver solutions
with a combination of
people, AI, agentic AI,
but deliver it as a seamless experience.
So that's great, but
how do you achieve that?
So some of the challenges we're seeing,
and it's still a reality, tech debt.
We still have a lot of on-prem
or hosted solutions, lots of mainframe.
So one of the biggest challenges
is the legacy infrastructure
that is still prevalent
in a lot of large enterprises.
Lack of gen AI and CX skills at scale.
We are all talking about it,
and there's usually a small
subset of these capabilities,
but it is not easily accessible.
We see a lot of promise and hype
of what AI can deliver,
but in some instances,
we're not necessarily seeing
the actual ROI calcs.
Or, you know, there's a lot of POC
or POV solutions, but it's not
necessarily being taken out
and scaled into production.
Complexity, most clients
have multi-vendor solutions,
a combination of legacy,
cloud, different vendors.
And whilst there's a
lot of interoperability
and integration, there is
still a lot of complexity
in terms of how you stitch
all of that together.
Probably the most important
is around governance,
security, and compliance.
We've seen one of the
biggest challenges is,
I'm sure you guys have seen examples,
where AI has completely changed
the data that we can make
accessible to clients,
data that we make accessible
to our own agents and employees.
And being able to manage and
govern that is really key.
So I wanna go through,
what does our AWS portfolio look like?
What is a typical
engagement with a client?
So we do everything from advisory,
which I've spoken about.
And on the advisory, very important,
the focus is not about features
and capabilities with CCAS and CX.
The focus is about understanding
business requirements.
We look at customer experience maturity,
we look at CX benchmarking.
We look at specific use cases,
because ultimately the technology
and all of the capabilities
needs to address business challenges.
On the implementation side,
focus is on professional services.
So all of the build and
implementation capabilities.
But the professional
services are really important
because it is not just
about configuration,
it is about customization.
It is about delivering bespoke solutions,
relevant, tailored to our
client's specific requirements.
No matter what anybody says,
we've never seen two solutions alike.
It comes back to the ecosystem,
it comes back to the requirements,
it comes back to the different verticals
and your specific business drivers.
And coming back to the
theme of effortless CX,
I know that is a charged statement,
'cause CX is anything but
effortless, highly complicated.
A lot of you here nodding,
so I take it that you know
exactly, you know, how
challenging that can be.
But our focus has been on,
how do we simplify that?
So managing and operating,
building out managed services,
and I'll go through a lot
more of what that means.
But everything from
what we'll call day two,
post-implementation, how do you manage it?
How do you operate it?
How do you make sure that
it's actually delivering
what we set out to deliver?
And on the managed services side,
what we've tried to do is really take away
a lot of that complexity.
So standard deployment with Connect,
we have global service
desks with local presence.
We've got level 1, 2, 3 support.
Most importantly we have,
and this is an interesting one,
unlimited MACDs, or
moves, ads, and changes.
Because in the contact center
it's not a static environment,
it's a dynamic environment that
needs changes all the time.
And what we found is that when we deliver
our managed service and clients
say, "Hey, listen, you know,
change my call flows, my IVR,
you know, change my bots."
It was contradictory to say we provided
as a managed service,
but every single time,
we need to build out a statement of work
and there's a whole process to do
what should be basic changes.
Or not necessarily basic,
but essential changes to a contact center.
So the managed service is really key,
making sure that you
got predictable costs,
you've got access to the
right skills, support,
full visibility into your CX environment.
So we make available a
portal where all of the data,
reporting on the entire
solution is available
and accessible to our clients.
And fundamentally, what
we've also done is,
how do we know that the
solution and services
are actually delivering as intended?
So standard part of the solution
is synthetic testing, or bots,
that emulate our clients and customers.
So whether it is on voice
or any digital channel,
we can dial in, listen
to the IVR, step through,
really emulating what an end
customer experience would be.
Because, you know, it doesn't help
whether it's a vendor
issue, a config issue,
or whatever it is, if there's impact,
we need to know about it,
and we need to know about it proactively.
So, very interesting topic,
AI agents versus human agents.
Well, I think, you know, it
goes without saying, right,
on the AI agent side,
we are starting to see
a lot of routine,
high-volume, scalable tasks.
And this is where we're starting to see
the most amount of adoption.
Frontline automation, some
of the personalization
and tailored solutions I've touched on.
But really where AI agents
is replacing traditional IVRs,
it can do it at the fraction of a cost,
far better experience.
I mean, how frustrating
is it to dial into an IVR,
versus being able to
converse with an AI bot?
So if we look at AI agents,
anything that is simple,
repetitive, predictable.
But we're slowly starting to close the gap
in terms of the level of
complexity and what bots can do.
You know, we see it changing
every two to three months.
You know, you guys have
seen over the last few days
in terms of the announcements
and the advancements we're
seeing, it's unbelievable.
What we are actually struggling
is to keep up with that
pace of innovation,
and continuing to adopt and embrace
a lot of the newer capabilities.
But I really believe that the
human agents are here to stay
in a very different,
specific, and focused role.
So handling a lot more of the complexity.
You know, somebody asked
me a question around,
"Can AI deliver empathy?"
And it's a very interesting question.
I'm sure you guys have got a view on it.
Well, it can fake empathy really well,
but can it deliver empathy?
Well, it depends.
So handling empathy, you know,
varying transactions,
unpredictable queries,
that is where people and, you know,
we spoke about the various...
Just this morning, Swami spoke about
reinforcement learning, right?
So how do you pull
together people to support,
scale your AI capabilities?
This is one of the innovation
and investments we've
made partnering with AWS.
So really, really
interesting and, you know,
hopefully this will
resonate with you guys.
We've seen, in the contact
center and CX space
over the last few years,
everybody went to digital, omnichannel,
chat, email, social, decline of voice.
But the decline of voice wasn't as great
as everybody thought it would be.
The interesting thing is
that over the last 12 months,
we've seen a significant
resurgence of voice, why?
In fact voice is becoming
the new dominant digital channel.
We've always had IVR and
we have conversational IVR,
but it's frustrating.
You know, you guys dial in
and you speak to this
computer-automated voice
and you've got to wait for it.
But if you use any of the
newer agentic AI solutions,
it is intuitive, low latency.
You can have a fluid conversation,
you can interrupt it at any time.
And all of a sudden, it is very different.
You can talk with whatever dialect,
you can talk in different languages,
but the most important point
is the fact that it is low latency.
And it is no different
to you having a conversation
with another person.
So what we've done as NTT is built out
an agentic AI comms gateway
that stitches together
and enables voice solutions.
So we can have
all of the security,
all of the voice managed securely.
And the ability to connect
to different systems for orchestration,
different LLM models, and not just voice,
but adding in other channels.
So just to share with you
guys what that looks like.
Because in any contact center,
and it's not just about Connect,
Connect is absolutely core,
but if we look at some of
the broader ISV partners
that Amazon has, Genesis, Nice, et cetera,
being able to stitch together voice
with various AI use cases,
pulling data from ITSM, CRM,
really any line of business system,
and managing that and making
it available in real-time.
Because what we've seen is that
everybody wants to build out
these use cases, but where do you start?
How do you get the voice?
How do you secure it?
Who's gonna manage it?
And once again, you may
have multiple partners,
multiple carriers, multiple systems.
So the focus is really on the ability
to create repeatable,
composable solutions.
AI-driven sourcing, and I think, you know,
I'm gonna hand over to
Priyen in a few minutes.
But I wanna focus on, what
does AI-driven sourcing mean?
Well, contact centers have
been people-driven forever.
I spoke about offshoring,
everybody's familiar with
onshoring or near-shoring.
But what we've seen
is that it's no longer about people costs,
because you can build an agentic AI bot
that is completely autonomous.
Or it can manage several solutions,
depending on the level of complexity,
and then hand over to an
agent with full context.
So to put that into perspective,
when you run a contact center,
typically everybody focuses on things
like average handle time.
And the average handle time
is usually between four to six minutes,
depending on the vertical
or the nature of transaction,
the level of complexity.
If I just look at some of
the use cases out of Shed,
Q and A, or knowledge use case,
based on the cost, and
onshore is really based
on North America and some of Europe.
So based on the handle time
of that four to six minutes,
the cost of those agents,
it's usually about six to $10.
And we've seen it over
the last 15, 20 years,
offshoring to low cost
geographies, fantastic.
Significantly lower cost, you can see,
typically, three to four, maybe $5.
But it comes with its own
challenges in terms of language,
in terms of being able
to represent brands.
And now we've got agentic AI solutions
that can really deliver it
at the fraction of a cost.
But it's not just about the cost,
it increases things like
customer satisfaction,
net promoter score.
In some instances I mentioned,
certain industries, public sector,
healthcare, financial services,
they may or may not wanna
offshore based on sensitivity,
based on regulations that
they need to comply to.
So what we seeing is that agentic AI
can deliver these solutions.
And one of the most important use cases
is in the contact center,
because there's demonstrable value.
You know, you can have a
look at a business case
and there's immediate value
in terms of what you can do,
how you can do it.
Because the first thing when
you have conversations is,
what is the business case?
What is the return on investment?
When will we realize that?
When you have people costs,
there is very real, tangible results.
And I know that it opens
up a broader question
in terms of the people management.
But we've seen that a lot of enterprises
are repurposing and upskilling
a lot of those agents to do higher level,
higher complexity, more customization.
More personalized, you know,
solutions or engagement where,
like I said, empathy is needed.
So, very interesting space.
Really important is that these solutions
are being deployed,
being deployed at scale,
and the value that we're seeing,
the value to our clients,
and ultimately passing that on
to their end customers is phenomenal.
So, last slide and I'll
hand over to Priyen
to get into a lot more
detail around the innovation
and specifically what
we're doing with Connect.
Another example of what
we've done is Foresight.
This is our own IP as NTT
Real-time speech analytics.
We hold quite a few patents on it.
Our speech engine, all powered by AWS.
The ability to do true real-time.
So you know, you could be an
agent in the contact center.
Firstly, it could be a highly
compliant contact center,
where if the agent
didn't say, "Hey, listen,
I need to tell you this call is recorded."
The agent may make a recommendation
that is actually against a company policy,
immediately can be flagged.
You may have an irate customer
who says, "Hey, listen,
this is the third time I'm calling in and,
you know, I'm really upset."
In real-time, it flags certain keywords.
It can pass it on to a supervisor
who can either coach the agent.
Or more importantly, just
get into the call and say,
"Hey, listen, how can I assist?
Let me help you."
Post COVID, everybody's
seen remote working,
it's the new norm.
So how do you manage contact center agents
who are no longer
physically in front of you?
As a supervisor, I could walk
the contact center floor,
I've got 10 to 15 agents,
and I could manage them.
Now, they could be sitting
anywhere in the world.
So some of the tools we've
got, like virtual seat map,
it builds you a virtual
map of your agents,
what they're saying, what
they're doing, keywords.
And very simple green, amber, red.
I can understand where
the agents need support,
where they need nurturing.
I can have a look at who's
the best performing agent
based on what they do, the
FAQs, the knowledge base.
And I can use that for training purposes.
So a lot of that insights is
taken and fed back in terms of,
how do you improve the training,
the real-time management?
So just another example
of how we are building
these solutions for real use cases.
With that, I'd love to
introduce Priyen Pillay.
And he's gonna go into a lot
more detail on what we're doing
and how we're doing it
with Connect, thank you.
(congregants applauding)
- Thanks Sash, and good
intro to the topic.
I guess my portion of the presentation
is more on the applications
of what Sashen spoke about
from agentic AI perspective
and the different
technologies that we use.
I guess, to start off,
we've been doing this about nine years now
in terms of Amazon
connecting contact centers
and moving customers from
legacy solutions to the cloud.
So we were there when
there was no agentic AI,
we were there when it was just,
the buzzword was text-to-speech.
So using poly to no longer
have to have prerecorded messages,
that was the exciting bit nine years ago.
Then we moved into the space
of having other bits of innovation in.
So putting Lex in to have
conversational IVR for
predetermined intents.
And then slowly, as the years progressed,
we went into generative AI
and that was the last year,
probably the last 24 months
leading into the new phase of '26.
Essentially, the pattern we've always used
over the last nine years was Lego blocks.
And the reason why we use Lego blocks
is because a lot of people
believe Amazon Connect
is the only service that's
used in your contact center,
and that's brutally wrong.
The average AWS contact center user
from a enterprise level
uses on average 25 services
in AWS to empower the contact center.
So it's important that
everyone understands
that that's what makes
Amazon Connect powerful,
is the fact that you can
leverage the services around it.
Which is why we take
the Lego block approach,
to say that no two customers
contact centers are the same,
It's because no two customers
have the same business strategy.
If you did, it doesn't make you
a differentiator in the market.
So from an ecosystem perspective,
I guess there's nothing much
that can differentiate partners,
other than the way that
we stitch things together.
So on the left hand side,
you'll see the whole bunch of services.
And I'm not taking,
and NTT won't take any,
credit for the services
that Amazon provide.
They're very good in the market,
they're release things really quickly.
They listen to their partners,
they listen to the customers.
There's been instances where us as NTT
have put innovation bots
or feature enhancements
into their backlog because
of our customers needing
certain future enhancements
in the contact center.
And we've seen realization of that.
Some of the benefits coming out
of the new re:Invent
releases for Amazon Connect
around dynamic GUIs and
generative AI voices.
So now you no longer
pick a particular voice,
you can use generative AI
for your text-to-speech.
But essentially, what we've
been doing for the last eight,
nine years was the middle
bits of the Venn diagram.
So we've been building microservices
that stitch the three different parameters
in the contact center together.
The first one is, of
course, the AWS platform.
The second one is any
best-of-breed cloud native tools.
So, again, Amazon doesn't force you
to use everything from Amazon Connect.
You can bring the
best-of-breed, and there's ways
to get it to work seamlessly
in your contact center.
And then the last bit is,
not everyone migrates to
cloud at the same speed.
So you'll see that in most of the cases,
you've got APIs that are
still offered on-premise,
by on-premise gateways.
Not everything has moved to the cloud.
So that integration path between the cloud
and your network is extremely important.
Things like VDI connectivity for voice,
and those type of things.
So we spent the last nine
years building microservices
to stitch everything together.
And as with anything,
as the years progress,
we got a lot better.
And we've got a lot of automations running
that can make migrations a lot quicker.
However, the caveat is, as we got better
at the existing stuff, there
were new stuff being released.
So it's a continuous cycle.
Some of the areas that were
exciting, (coughs), excuse me.
exciting about five years ago.
So Contact Lens, which
is speech analytics.
Self-service, so getting
more automation in,
so you don't have to wait in queues.
And then some of the
other functionalities,
like chatbots with Lex, et cetera.
So those were innovations
that drove change
into Amazon Connect over the
last potentially five years.
And then we realized that,
to the point I was
saying of microservices,
we then went into thinking
about, how could we safely
deploy contact centers quicker?
How could we reuse
patterns that we've learned
over the various
customers we take care of,
into new customers or
to existing customers
that are a bit slower at
getting to innovation parts?
And that's where we worked
with our infrastructure
team to build NAMS.
So what NAMS is, is essentially,
we first had to believe
in the generative AI
for us to be able to
offer it to our customers.
So what NAMS is, NAMS is a
generative AI release tool
that we use to build packages
of components of contact center.
So what that means is
that we've prepackaged
components that we think are valuable
to customers for innovation,
or are valuable to customers
that are moving to the cloud.
Things like dynamic contact center flows,
things like bots for certain
servicing areas in
customers' contact centers.
So we've packaged all of this good stuff
and we've made it available in a catalog,
where NAMS is now used
to run it much quicker
and build it dynamically in
different customer environments.
The important bit for
NAMS is the fact that
we've also incorporated security protocols
and security checks, which
allow us to safely deploy it.
And allow code to be safely
scanned and become ready
for deployment in the
customer environments.
which then also allows us to use gen AI
to empower our engineers
that are shipped off
at our customers to do
the different deployments.
So, thus, offering quality at scale.
So we started this initiative
and it's an ongoing initiative.
But we started this initiative,
we worked with the generative AI process.
And then we've got to a
point where, you know,
we've eaten our own dog
food, we believe in the tech.
And now, we're going into our customers
to put the generative AI field in
from a CX and UX perspective.
So what we then did is we looked
at all our customers in general.
So I'm gonna quickly skim through
three different customers of
three different landscapes.
Yes, they're FSI, but
different regions of the world,
different customer base.
The first one is a very big African FSI
with a large range of customers
of different demographics.
So different earning
potentials, different dialects,
different patterns of spend,
different interaction
patterns, different ages.
So that's the first type of customer.
The second type was also an FSI
that is a lot newer to the market.
They're a much younger customer base.
They were also for the people,
so they were more of
the lower to mid earners
of the customer base.
And then the last one
is a European bank that,
again, very ambitious, they
had a very mature estate,
they needed to move that to the cloud.
They do have the European
market, so a lot of youngsters
at this customer, a lot
of different dialects
because of the multinationals
that live in the country.
So all three of these different
logos had something similar,
even though their passion
of business was different.
It was, how do we service
our customers quicker?
How do we reduce our operational spend?
And how do we ensure
that CX goes up without,
well, CS goes up, but opex goes down,
from a spend perspective?
Which results in the customers in general
wanting one thing, is generative AI.
It's a buzzword, everyone
wants to put generative AI in.
The important bit was,
how do you do it safely?
So in the next slide, it's
gonna be a voice note playing
of one of the bots that we built.
Again, you can make it sound
as realistic as you want,
especially with the new release
that came out now at re:Invent.
But what we wanted to figure out is,
what is the correct pattern
between gen AI, agentic AI,
and all these different NLP bots
that customers would've
had when they built Lex,
when Lex was buzzword a couple years ago?
- [AI bot] Hi, I'm (indistinct),
AI service assistant,
how can I help you?
- [Marnus] Hi, can you please
tell me more about NTT?
- [AI bot] NTT Data is a global leader
in IT services and digital transformation.
If you need more specific
details, feel free to ask.
- [Marnus] What services can NTT offer?
- [AI bot] NTT data offers
a wide range of services,
including digital transformation,
consulting, managed services.
They provide cutting-edge
technology solutions
to various industries such as finance,
healthcare, government, and manufacturing.
If you need more specific information
about any of these
services, just let me know.
- [Marnus] Thank you for that.
What are the key drivers
of digital transformation
according to NTT Data?
- [AI bot] According to
NTT Data, the key drivers
of digital transformation are
improved customer experience,
operational efficiency,
ability to innovate,
and adapt to market changes.
If you need more details
on any of these drivers,
feel free to ask.
- [Marnus] I was wondering
if we can actually
schedule an appointment
with NTT for a demo?
- [AI bot] Sure, I can help you with that.
Could you please provide
your email address,
so I can look up your contact record
and proceed with
scheduling the appointment?
- [Marnus] Okay, that's
marnus.botha@global.ntt.
- [AI bot] Great, I found
your contact record.
What date would you like
to schedule the demo for?
- [Marnus] Tomorrow at around 12.
- [AI bot] The available
time slots for tomorrow
are 8:00 AM to 10:00 AM,
12:00 PM to 2:00 PM, 4:00 PM to 5:00 PM.
Would you like to schedule the
demo for 12:00 PM to 2:00 PM?
- [Marnus] Yep, that's fine.
- [AI bot] Your demo with NTT
has been successfully
scheduled for tomorrow
from 12:00 PM to 2:00 PM.
If you need any further
assistance, feel free to ask.
- [Marnus] Awesome, thank
you so much. Cheers, goodbye.
- [AI bot] You're
welcome. Have a great day.
- So the voice note is not
meant to be be-all, end-all
of what agentic AI can do.
We understand there's much
better ways to have the bot
to be more human-like,
to be more seamless.
There's varied use cases to both
for agentic AI and generative AI.
But what we tried to do with
that particular use case
was that was built overnight.
We took an engineer, we
gave them particular APIs,
we created dummy APIs
for particular use cases,
simulating readily available APIs
at our customer's workspace.
And we created dummy
profiles which mimicked CRM.
And we asked the engineer
to build something
of value that had two different journeys,
a structured and an unstructured journey.
The reason why we asked for that
is because the whole
point of generative AI
in the contact center is
so that you can minimize
the differential points that customers
enter your contact center.
And have a single point of
entry that can understand,
guide, and navigate that customer
to the right point of your contact center.
15 years ago, that was a phone number.
So a phone number will
get you to the right area.
So we know when you dial the phone number,
we roughly know why you wanna
get to the contact center.
Then that phone number
went to it a DTMF IVR
to get to a queue,
because then that shrunk
your requirements even more.
So we pinpoint and said okay,
they phoned this phone number,
there's four queues, they're going to Q3.
So these are roughly the agents
that I should send this call
to, or this interaction to.
The point of generative
AI in the contact center
is so that that bot can minimize
the amount of manual filtering
that we are doing in the contact center.
And subsequently service
simultaneously for things
that we do know should be
helped in the contact center.
So an unstructured fulfillment,
which is the top journey,
is essentially, I don't know why
I'm calling the contact center.
I don't know what my
customer's gonna need,
but I know they need something.
So that bot should be able to understand
a variation of inputs,
and roughly navigate the
customer to the correct journey.
That correct journey could be a queue,
it could be another self-service,
or it could be a knowledge article.
So in an unstructured fulfillment,
what we realize is the best way
to build the conversational bot,
or the chatbot that
needs to be more dynamic,
is to have the unstructured
journey as a parent bot
that's linked to a large
knowledge article base.
And that large knowledge
article base has to be cleaned,
and different customers have
different levels of clean data.
The important part is garbage
in, garbage out, right?
So you could not expect the bot
to be brilliant at everything.
The cleaner the data, the
more structured the data,
the easier the bot will find it.
We did some tests where
we had very dirty data,
and then we had very clean data.
And there was a 50% higher time to answer,
'cause remember the bot is
computing when you give it input.
And then a 50% to a 60% better,
or more quality response
where it meant something to me
as the asker of the question.
So a big part of our generative AI journey
is that cleaning of data.
So that gives you your
unstructured journey.
So the generative AI bot journey.
Once the generative AI bot
picks up what you need,
and let's assume you need something
that I have a process flow, a map flow,
i.e., your traditional self-service,
I then send you to a child
bot, which is generally Lex,
which you can do today.
And Lex does the API calls
to fulfill your journey,
so that you don't have to put the customer
back into a different
self-service journey.
You just put it into a different bot
using the handing over
from the parent to child.
And it can be multiple child bots
fulfilling multiple API journeys.
The important bit there
that made that successful
is the quality of the APIs,
the speed of the APIs.
And then the last bit is,
how often are people
actually gonna use this?
So what we generally do in this instance
is we do a scope of the customer's estate.
And do a narrative in terms of,
what's the most used journeys?
And generally, that also
comes out of your interviews
with agents, et cetera, to understand,
why are customers calling you?
'Cause agents, believe it or not,
would know your contact center
better than execs running it,
because they are underground
talking to the customers.
So you spend a lot of time with the agents
when designing these process flows.
So that's the customer facing one.
Now, what we're working on
is the user facing agentic AI.
So you replace the top half,
which is knowledge repositories,
and you replace that with models
built on contact center data.
So what we're working on
and what our plan for FY '26
for our existing customers is to input
a agentic contact center manager.
But it's not meant to replace
contact center managers,
it's meant to enhance them and
get their job done quicker.
We listened over the last 10 years,
we listened for what the pain points are.
SLAs are the biggest item
in the contact center.
Every contact center
manager that I've ever met,
said every customer only
cares about SLAs, why?
Because that is the single
metric that generally is used
to judge how well a contact
center is performing.
So everyone does a whole
bunch of funny things
to keep their SLAs up.
But what if you had a bot, or a model,
that could preemptively make
decisions to keep that SLA up?
Because there's rules
at the end of the day.
Yes, it's one person that
understands the business
that's making those
rules, and that's selfish
to build your business
around that one person.
So you should rather
build a model around it.
And that's what we're working on now,
is the different variations
of models for contact centers
that take things like operational stats,
survey scores, agents, evaluations,
so that you can do things
like move agents in real-times
before enrouting profiles
to keep your SLAs up.
If a person is calling for the fifth time
into the contact center
for the same thing,
that means that you definitely
need to get that person
to the right agent.
And the right agent is generally the agent
with the lowest handling time,
the highest evaluation scores,
and the highest survey
scores statistically.
So that bot will decide and
put it into that agent queue,
so that agent can help the person
whose calling for the first time.
So in totality, that's
what our plan is for '26,
is to help the users now
manage their contact centers better.
Thank you.
This is just a screenshot of
a QR code that can be used
to see one of our use cases,
but I'll open the floor to questions.
Sorry there's only about
five minutes, but, yeah.